this is a production of Cornell
University
alright next we have Laura Kaminsky
Laura's from Rochester New York her
scientific winters are treble Brent
Thompson attorney Tom Mison her post
graduation plan she's going to be doing
a six month long apprenticeship at seven
point form in Connecticut and then we'll
be programming under the title of Lord
talk today is phosphorous and soil
microbiome of alfalfa
hi everyone my name is Laura and today
I'll be talking about my senior honors
thesis which I did in the keratin lab
and we used a variety of soil ecology
techniques to study microbial and micro
biome is just the collection of all
bacteria and fungi in the soil
interacting with each other and
interacting plant and these the
composition and activity is those micro
bonds cannot really profound impact on
plant phenotypes and platform ins so
specifically my study I look at how
phosphorus fertilization impacts that
interaction and platforms so in this
talk I'll first go over the backgrounds
that led me to develop this study i'll
then discuss the methods I used I'll go
over just a couple of my results and the
conclusions that we can case so to start
off a brief overview of the phosphorus
cycle so place required phosphorus in
this form the phosphate ion and they
take it up through their roots from the
soil solution however most phosphorus in
the soil exists in some other form at
the inaccessible place so this includes
large organic molecules that have
phosphorus in them the pocket I can
become bound to soil minerals and it can
also precipitate out of solution in
these insoluble complexes
fortunately microbes are really good at
turning those inaccessible forms of
phosphorus back into the phosphate ions
which plants can then use and
furthermore microbes are also really
important in helping twice Gaza's
phosphate ions once they are available
so the or muscular mycorrhizae fungi
form in symbiosis with plant roots and
simultaneously colonize a larger volume
of the soil and plants could reach on
their own so also microbes are very
important for making a spa a time
available and helping plants acquire it
1/6 however we as humans just bypass
this whole cycle in our agricultural
systems by directly applying inorganic
fertilizers to our soils the problem
with this is that that phosphate ion
applied for the soil can really quickly
turn back into those inaccessible forms
such that only 10 to 30 percent of
what's applied is actually taken up by
the plants and the rest remains in soil
you can imagine that over the years this
can cause washers to build to really
really high levels in soil and this is a
well-documented issue from water quality
because if that soil runoff into water
that employ nutrients can cause algal
blooms fish kills and host of other
problems they will be resistant
something that is a little bit less
researches once all of that excess
phosphorus doing to the soil microbes
that are so important for phosphorous
cycling especially and this is an
important question for sustainable
agriculture specifically transitioning
to more sustainable forms of nutrient
management because we're going to have
to increasingly rely on these microbes
as opposed to these fertilizers which
come from a non-renewable sources
require a lot of energy to make so we're
interested in how the previous
fertilization management techniques may
have been affecting microbes which we're
going to meet in future so is the phase
for this study
so I addressed this question for good
reasons
the first was just field soil from one
of Cornell farms mixed with a little bit
of peat moss to lighten it up and then
to that base soil mix I had three
phosphorus addition treatments the first
was a composition to add an organic form
of phosphorus one of the day accessible
forms and that was just acquired from
oil harm sources and then I had two
inorganic phosphorus treatments and a
triple super phosphate which is just a
very concentrated form of that phosphate
ion the first was a relatively moderate
rate of triple super phosphate and the
other was designed to just be completely
ridiculous and overload the soil with
more process than plants could possibly
use so those are my four soil treatments
and to those for soil treatments I
applied a multi generation conditioning
of a common starting with microbiome so
what this meant was I had twenty
replicate pots of each treatment and in
the my group alpha which is just
important for each crop
oh please the cover crops because the
legumes and it fixes nitrogen so it's
important in the Northeast so I have 20
pounds of alfalfa for each treatment
I grew those for 3 weeks and when I
harvest into place and I drive them down
and I collected the above-ground biomass
and I identified the four tops with the
highest biomass plants and some of those
tops
I took the soil I took the microbiome
and I've transplanted that into a steam
sterilized soil of the same treatment so
I chose to create micro vials that were
associated with the highest plant growth
for each of the four treatments
separately so this method has been used
recently to show that you can actually
alter plant traits in this way without
changing point genomics at all as an end
up happening in this case that is I
didn't end up improving violence by
selecting my crimes in this way but that
was the basic idea behind this method
okay so the end of four generations of
conditioning I ended up with four
distinct microbiome and disease I
performed a reciprocal transplant so
that just means that I put each of the
four different microbiome into each of
the four different soil that's for a
total of 16 crops so why did I do this
well I was really interested in the
effects of having a micro biomes with
different compositions and seeing if
those different micro biomes had
different effects on plant growth the
problem with my setup was that the
different soil treatments also had
different abiotic properties and those
separately affected by growth so for
example the plants grow the compost
would grow differently the plants grown
just in the base soil mix just on their
own at the same time that how both is
also altering soil properties in such a
way that the microbiome is responding
and altering as well and that altered
microbiome is having a secondary effect
altering plant growth so is that a
second effect that I'm interested in but
it's very difficult to tease it apart
just as my experimental setup so we
current this with their typical
transplant by putting four different
micro biomes in
- the same a bionic soil treatments and
then if you see at the same time
differences in plant growth you can be
reasonably sure that the effect is
because of the microbiome and not
because of the soil types so that was
spaces behind the receptacle transplant
my hypotheses for this experiment where
the at the end of my four generations of
selections of conditioning microbiomes I
was indeed have four distinct micro
biomes they would have different
compositions and different enzyme
activities that sort of thing I was
exhausted this distinct community
fingerprint which maintains inner circle
transplants even when they think micro
biomes are put into new soils they
maintain some of their characteristic
properties I also thought that for any
given soil in the reciprocal transplant
the plants that would perform the best
would be the one that is grown with
microbiome that's already adapted to
that soil but so for example in the
compost soil I thought that plants would
grow best when they're grown micro
bottoms already adapted to the compost
soil as opposed to microphones that were
adapted to one of the inorganic
phosphorus treatments for examples so I
wasn't hell off data I don't have time
to talk about it all today but I checked
I was in micro biome in two ways first
I've sequence the 16s RNA gene which
just give me a stash out of all the
bacterial diversity that's present in
the soil I also measured an
extracellular enzyme activity just to
get a sense of nutrient balance and
nutrient needs of that microbial
ecosystem for plant for the alfalfa I
measured biomass and for the simple
transplant only I also measured
nodulation of those observers and I
measured plant mineral concentrations of
carbon nitrogen and phosphorus but today
are really just talking about sequencing
data and the biomass data from their
simple transplants but very quickly my
first hypothesis was confirmed at the
end of my four generations of
conditioning I had four distinct
microphones and they were distinct both
in bacterial community composition and
in enzymes
activity and this is the sequencing data
for their circle transplant relating to
my second hypothesis so what this is is
a principle coordinate analysis graph
and basically what it does is it
condenses that enormous amount of data
that I have on bacterial species that
are present in the soil for each sample
it condenses that huge multivariate data
set into two items and so when two
points that are closer together on this
graph that means that their community
composition is more similar and when
they're further apart means their
community composition is more different
so points are colored on this graph by
their microbial history what soil were
they present to for generation of
selection and then points are shaped by
which soil they are currently in
prettier culture so the first thing you
notice is that points cluster most
closely with other points that are the
same color and the same shape so there's
most similar to other microbiome sharing
the same cross with inner circle
transplants more broadly points
clustered by their current soil types so
for example all the microbiomes that are
currently in a control soil cluster
together here
no matter the microbiome history the
same is true the compost amend the soil
and it seems true the low in organic
phosphorus well the exception to this
pattern may notice far as the microbes
that are from historically highly
fertilized soil say touring this broader
cluster with every microbiome that is
currently or have in the past
bins that really highly fertilized soils
in other words they maintain their
stations so in relation to my second
hypothesis it was only those higher and
Vanek phosphorus micro biomes that
maintain their distinction and the rest
of them converged pretty rapidly in tune
decomposition of when put into image
file types so how does this relate to
the biomass inch plug performance so
this is a picture of all my replicate
fives from serviceable transplants a
random subset of my pops
representing each of the 16 process so
popular arranged in rows by their soil
treatments and in columns by the
microbiome that was transplanted into
that pop so the first thing is you'll
notice and here I'll be flashing my
biomass data panels up to the right and
I'll show you that data again in the
next slide that sleazy orient those
those panels to this picture so the
first thing you'll notice is that the
place in the back row that we're growing
the couple of cemented soil
overall just do the best there's they're
tall they're green they look really nice
and that's true across the board no
matter which my file was transplanted it
on the opposite end of the spectrum you
have the slicing in front row which were
growing into really highly fertilized
soil and you can see that they're small
and they're stunted and they look yellow
and there are some website and that's
suppose the tree pretty much across the
board and then the two so a little the
controller will we realized soil our
intermediate between that but what's
really interesting here are these these
pops in this rightmost column which were
passed where the hives fertilized
microbiome strand sighted it and you can
see in comparison to other tops and sing
grow those plants are yellow and
expression and we're listing you so they
look massive great so that's quite
interesting so we see this reflected in
the biomass data as well so these three
columns correspond to the tree pasta I
had circles and you can see in
comparison to other bars in the same
panel so two other pops that was on the
same soil type these have significantly
lower by mass than the other plants
within the same soil treatment so that's
quite an interesting build
so there's raffles altogether I found
that at the end of generation board I
had four distinct micro biomes plus one
of those were typically translations we
soils only the highly fertilized micro
biomes
maintains one of their community
footprint correspondingly plants grown
with that microbiome had a lower
violence
periodicals lower percent nation and
they were yellow and stunted in
comparison to other questions that were
grown in the same soil just with other
microphones so what we can conclude from
this is that really excessive or
repeated inorganic phosphorus
fertilization may be changing the
microbiome in such a way that it was
able to support plant growth
particularly alcohol occur so some quite
important in transition to sustainable
agriculture because it suggests that we
will have to do some reclamation work on
our microbiomes before they're back to
the sort of nutrient cycling that we
will need them to be at in order to
function so with that a lot of people
thank you my three mentors Jay Arneson
Terry Bell and grant Thompson thanks
also to everyone on the plant science
honours committee thanks everyone
my lab who helped me out with various
pieces of the work to Q's accounting
model took a very long time thanks to
Qin armed services for providing this
well in the compost to get certainly
thanks to several people who helped me
design a semi and interpret my
statistics and finally to undergraduate
grants which help support this work
please
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu